As you're looking around the editor, we just want to highlight a few key areas that you
may want to look for when interfacing with the Unreal Editor.
So at the top, we've got the menu bar.
You'll see that green play button there, which is what we use to jump into our experience.
And you can also select a few different modes.
You may be wanting to place content in your scene.
You may want to be adding foliage or landscape.
That's where you'll select the different modes from.
That will also be where we can compile our blueprints.
We can create cinematics and we can also create an executable, depending on the platform that
we want to, whether we're packaging for a PC or a mobile or some other platform, which
is your intended output.
So the menu bar is at the top there.
The main viewport here is in number two, which we were navigating before.
I'll put some useful prompts on the screen in a second to help you navigate through the
editor.
The World Outliner is essentially a list of all the content that is within the scene.
So you'll see everything selected there.
If I jump back over to my editor, you'll see in the World Outliner, you'll see everything
listed.
And as I click the cube, it selects the cube inside the map.
So it's just a big list of everything that's inside of the scene.
If you double click anything, you'll go straight to it inside the editor.
So very powerful.
It houses all the information that is part of your project to look through.
And it's just a very useful list to be able to navigate.
And then we've got the details panel, which will give you details of any specific actor.
If I hop on over to my editor again, you'll be able to see that we've got a whole bunch
of properties here based on the location, the rotation, what static mesh is being used,
the material, all these lists of properties that come as standard inside of Unreal Engine,
which will allow you to create the content in the desired effect that you want it to be.
When we're navigating the viewport, as we mentioned previously, you can use mouse navigation.
You can use it to look around.
You can also change the camera speed, which is useful if you're moving either too quickly
or too slowly.
And to do that in the editor, you can select the camera on the top right-hand side here
and set the camera speed to whatever you would like it to be, along with the camera scalar there.
We can also use the WSD keys to move around, which I was referring to before, and the Q
and E keys to go up and down.
If you didn't want to use your mouse to move up and down, you can use Q and E. And then
C and Z controls the field of view to get the desired effect that you may want.
We've got mayor style controls, so F is to fit to frame, Alt and Left mouse button to
tumble in orbit, and Alt and Right mouse button to dolly.
And again, some just useful viewport navigation hotkeys here in case you wanted to save their
and just remind yourself of navigating the interface.